il y a un an et demi le cinéma le
grenier à sel s'est associé avec la
compagnie déclic théâtre qui est donc la
compagnie de trappes de théâtre
d'improvisation pour la création d'un
tout nouveau genre de spectacles cinéma
qui s'appelle plan c'est le cinéma
improvisé les il ya cinq comédiens sur
scène est un musicien le public décide
du thème musical et du thème visuel
c'est totalement improvisée donc les
comédiens ne savent pas ce qui va se
passer
et à partir de ces éléments visuels et
sonores ils vont devoir inventer un
nouveau film et pendant la soirée ils
vont inventer trois films ce sera donc
le jeudi 3 mai à 20h45 au cinéma le
grenier à sel il faut réserver sur le
site de déclic théâtre mais de vous
trouver tout ça sur notre site internet
cinéma grenier à sel point com